je m'appelle simone il narre 1952 et
aujourd'hui je vais défini je veux
dessiner en vélo mais le vélo il a des
ailes et on se couche dessus parce que
quand tu es fatigué comme ça que je peux
dormir je le donnerais bien à ton tour j
il fait jamais de sport parce qu'il est
trop fatigué si les excuses
la bicyclette pour cyclistes fatigué
préférant la position allongée est
instantanément transformable en
aéroplane et qui rêvait ressemble
maintenant je vais dessiner une voiture
mais ma voiture à la toile elle a un
balcon et puis on peut aller sur le
balcon et dans les longs voyages
on peut se dégourdir les jambes s'en
sortir de la voiture
ma maison elle est trop petite il
faudrait des maisons faites comme des
lego comme ça quand on a besoin d'une
pièce on l'a rajoute par dessus et là
moi et mon petit frère on serait plus
dans la même chambre
moi j'aurais laniel et lui il serait
dans une autre mais vraiment très très
loin se multiplier à la verticale comme
à l'horizontale
mais en fait ce qui serait bien c'est
qu'on le puisse faire ça avec des
maisons entières aussi citer voisin
t'embête tu peut en changer ça plairait
beaucoup à les parents ça et quand on
s'ennuie on peut déménager sans faire de
cartons pourquoi s'arrêter à la maison
je pourrai refaire la ville
si on creuse il y aurait plein de classe
sous sol et les bâtiments sont le dessus
pourraient ne jamais s'arrêter
faut-il croire que les gratte-ciel
eux-mêmes sont déjà dépassés avant
d'avoir envahi les villes
il suffit de lever les yeux pour s'en
rendre compte
l'an 2000 nous guette mer est à dire
qu'elles passent trop de temps à la
cuisine
ce qui serait bien ce serait que toute
la cuisine phase de travail à sa place
par exemple une machine qui peut faire
n'importe quel repas comme ça tu peux
faire plein de rêves sont fermes à
l'empoigné comme ça le poulet qu'il puis
tout seul
maman elle rendrait plus jamais cet art
et personne ne mourrait de faim
dans un grasser vous choisirez le plat
que vous désirez la carte perforée
correspondante introduite dans une
machine vous expliquera visuellement
larsen tandis qu'un calculateur
électronique que belgrade osera les
ingrédients nécessaires et animera les
robots chargé de la préparation
en fait ce qu'il faudrait c'est un roman
qui fasse tous les trucs que toutes les
mamans veulent pas refaire comme ça elle
pourrait se reposer qui ferait le ménage
et les câlins et qui nous racontera des
histoires qui prendrait soin des gens
quand ils sont malades ou quand elles
s'inscrivent une femme très électrique
l autre jour tout le monde bienvenue à
tous
je suis très heureuse enfin à paris sa
serais bien sa personne n'ira jamais
faire mais il faudrait qu'on me fasse
mais moi je pourrais le faire
[Musique]